congratulations iron man 3 uh fantastic
it is uh one of the most successful
movies of all time i know it's nuts
right people go crazy for it you were
just promoting the film in europe yes i
imagined that oh you were in london how
did you go in london it was it was great
you know it went over went over really
big we had a really huge premiere
everybody came out and did a lot of
press over there they were really like
you said they're wild about it right so
people people in uh in the uk are nice
to you well not i mean they're nice now
right you know they've
they finally stopped uh you know
attacking me because of the oceans the
dialect in the ocean's eleven you had
you had a british accent in uh uh
according to me i did
according to them i had
a piece of [ __ ] accident
they really got they get mad about that
you know yeah they got really mad about
it it was really upsetting they said you
remember dick van dyke i was like dick
are we talking mary poppins really it
was that
yeah dick van dyke and mary poppins and
i talked to dick van dyke about this he
said you know 50 years later
they're still mad at him because he was
like hello god not mary poppins
that is good yeah
well i'm very respected in england thank
you
yeah what are they upset about i don't
know
so so they still get mad about that
that's weird yeah i mean they i think
they really enjoyed the movie so i don't
think i'm completely off the hot seat no
i'm sure first movie i do the tanks
that's the next then they're back to
bitching
[ __ ] now you were just at comic-con you
promoted the movie at comic-con yeah
well we before it came out before that
two years ago and uh fans were rabid you
know i don't know if you guys ever been
anybody who ever been to comic-con yeah
i
it's bananas i have been to comic-con
and it's a level of insanity that you
you can't even imagine and then i'm
thinking okay you're going there with
the with the iron man films
they must their eyeballs just must melt
yeah it's it's it's very intense you
know that you want to do well there if
you don't you're going to hear about it
it feels kind of uh it could be
dangerous by the way you know dangerous
well the year we were there the uh a
harry potter i guess got pissed off at
somebody and put his you know little
wand through somebody's eye and i
actually heard about that yeah it was it
was in the news a harry potter fan who
was dressed as harry potter stabbed
someone with his wand because they got
into a nerd argument yeah yeah yeah
it's like you know gangster geeks i
guess
and i don't want any trouble i don't
want any trouble harry potter people but
they also have all kinds of i mean
they're all dressed up in costumes
there's all manner of of creature there
you know there's
and they don't necessarily have to be
cast in the way you know i saw a six
foot one yoda
really hey you know i decided i want to
be yoda yeah and he's 6-1 yes and made
no effort to like
scrunch down he tried to scrunch but he
was still sticking now what's it like
when you go uh with robert downey jr to
comic-con how do they respond to him oh
he's like he's a superstar you know he's
like mick jagger at comic con and he
comes on stage first and you know gives
him a little you know
lets him have that and they scream and
you know it's it's something to watch
he's a real uh he's a real conductor
yeah so he's like he takes control and
he completely takes control i mean in
the movie there's a moment at the end of
the movie where he you know
says snatches off his glasses and his
the voiceover says i am iron man you're
like
you you are iron man
can you say that on tbs no you can't uh
you can't say iron man at all you can't
say iron man or the f-word
you can't say comic-con
so
you can't say long john silver's uh
none of this show will air not
necessarily this is a podcast let's just
get our clothes off then